IT IS TURNED OUT TO BE THE MOST
OPAQUE.
>> THANK YOU NOW, BENJAMIN NOW
WHO IS NOW SET FOR THE THIRD
TIME TO BECOME ISRAEL'S NEXT
PRIME MINISTER RIGHT NOW HE IS
CURRENTLY IN TALKS TO BUILD TO
HIS COVENANT COALITION IN HIS
FLAG AND THE GOVERNMENT IN THE
INTERESTS OF ALL ISRAELIS.
IN MAY WHILE HE IS ALSO COMING
ON THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
REAFFIRM THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE SAUDIS WARMING OF THE
DANGERS TO THE WILD SWINGS IN
THAT RELATIONSHIP, ANYWAY HERE
TO EXPLAIN SO MUCH MORE THE
AUTHOR OF BB MY STORY, INCOMING
AND RARELY PRIME MINISTER THE
LONGEST-SERVING PRIME MINISTER
IN ISRAELI HISTORY, BENJAMIN
MIELE, MR. PRIME MINISTER IT IS
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO CALL YOU
THAT ONCE AGAIN, AND I THOUGHT
WE HAD A LOT OF ELECTIONS HERE
IN THE STATES BUT I THINK ISRAEL
TOPS ALL, YOU HAVE WHAT FIVE
ELECTION AND THREE YEARS?
>> WELL, WE'VE BECOME, JUMPING
OUT OF INNOVATION.
ON A GLOBAL SCALE.
AS YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGY, BUT IT
SEEMS TO BE THAT WE DO REDOING
THIS ALSO IN INSTABILITY OF
POLITICS.
BUT I'M VERY GOT TO SAY THAT THE
PEOPLE OF ISRAEL GIVE ME A VERY
STRONG VOTE OF CONFIDENCE, AND
WE HAVE AN ELECTION THAT FINALLY
DECIDED THE IMPACTS THAT WE'VE
HAD IN THEIR ISRAELI POLITICAL
SYSTEM.
AND WE ARE MOVING AHEAD FOR THE
BENEFIT AS YOU RIGHTLY QUOTED.
ALL THIS FOR ALL ISRAELIS HAVE
PEACE IN THE REGION, THE
RELIANCE BETWEEN ISRAEL AND US.
>> I DO NOT THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE ISRAEL
AND U.S. WAS STRONGER THAN WHEN
YOU AND PRIME MINISTER
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
THAT IS WHEN, OF COURSE, THE
EMBASSY GOT MOVED TO JERUSALEM
FROM TEL AVIV, THAT IS WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESIDENT TRUMP
RECOGNIZE ISRAEL'S RIGHT TO GO
LONG HEIGHTS, AND YOU HAD A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP OR SOMETHING
ELSE HAPPENED.
THE UNITED STATES ISRAELIS, AND
THE J.D. VANCE, AND THE SAUDIS,
AND THE EMIRATES, THEY ALL
UNITED AGAINST URANIAN YOU
GEMINI.
AND I'VE SAID MANY TIMES THAT
YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN THE VOICE
OF MORE CLARITY AGAIN TO
RADICALISM IN THE MIDEAST.
HE REMAINED THAT THAT SOLD VOICE
YET AGAIN TODAY.
I LOVE HER, THEY ARE ON BOARD
FOR A FULL IRAN WITH NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
>> THIS IS PRECISELY TOO, I
THINK THE RISE OF URANIAN
AGGRESSION, URANIUM POWER AND
HIS REQUEST FOR YOU FOR YOU WHEN
YOU WEAPONS THREATENS THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
THEY CHAT DEATH TO ISRAEL, DEATH
TO AMERICA AND OTHER INFIDELS IN
BETWEEN.
SO, LOCKING THEM WAS IMPORTANT
TO IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PIECE
OF OUR REGION AND THE PEACE OF
THE WORLD BUT ALONGSIDE THE RISE
OF URANIAN POWER IN THE RISE OF
ISRAELI POWER.
AND I TALK ABOUT BOOK HOW WE CAN
TRANSFORM ISRAEL FROM A
SOCIALIST ECONOMY TO ONE OF THE
MOST ROBUST RURAL ECONOMIES IN
THE WORLD.
AND WE EXPANDED OUR INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES AND CYBER
CAPABILITIES, AND AS A RESULT,
AND OTHER NOT HAPPEN ALONGSIDE
WITH THE THREAT OF VERIZON, THAT
IS THE CHANGE IN WHICH ARAB
LEADERS BEGAN TO LOOK AT ISRAEL,
AND THAT THEIR ENEMY, BUT IS THE
INDISPENSABLE ALLY TO CURB
URANIAN AGGRESSION ALSO TO
BENEFIT THE PEOPLE FROM OUR
INCREDIBLE TECHNOLOGY.
THAT CREATED THE BACKGROUND FOR
THE ABRAHAM ACCORDS WHICH IS
ACHIEVED WITH THE HELP OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS TEAM.
SO HE MADE FOR HISTORIC PEACE
ACCORD AND I MEAN MORE -- SO WE
HAVE IN OUR AREA TO THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING.
THE ONE THE RISE OF THE WORLD
WITH JAMES BECK COULD THREATEN
THE PEACE OF THE ENTIRE PLANET.
IN THE SECOND, THE RISE OF PEACE
TREATIES, THAT COULD SERVE BOTH
TO SAVE OFF AGGRESSION BUT ALSO
TO OFFER A BETTER FUTURE FOR ALL
AND BASICALLY, I'M COMING BACK
TO OFFICE TO ADVANCE BOTH GOALS.
BLACK IRAN AN EXPANDED PIECE.
>> I HOPE PEOPLE DO HAVE A
CHANCE TO PICK UP YOUR BOOK
ABOUT YOUR LIFE AND WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE LIFE YOU HAVE LED
PART OF AN ELITE MISSES MILITARY
FORCE ALONG WITH YOUR BROTHER,
YOUR BROTHER WAS KILLED AT THE
RAID IN YOUR LIFE STORY IS
PHENOMENAL, THE LONGEST-SERVING
PRIME MINISTER IN ISRAELI
HISTORY AND NOW BACK FOR A THIRD
TIME, WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING OUT IN THE WORLD STAGE,
AND STEADFASTLY STICKING UP FOR
THAT MORE CLARITY THAT I THINK
THE WORLD NEEDS TO ADHERE TO.
MR. PRIMUS AND I THANK YOU WITH
US.
>> THANK YOU SEAN, AND I LIKE
IT TIGHT.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
>> ABSENT A NEW ONE.
ALTHOUGH IT MIGHT GET OF IN
NATURE I DON'T KNOW.